the
workshop
um the first talk today is by noah
steven the freedomwits who will tell us
about the average case hardness of ksum
uh please know
uh okay great
so uh yeah hi i'm noah um and yeah i'll
be talking about uh the hardness of
average quesome um which is uh joint
work with uh zivika and vinod my two
lovely co-authors
um
okay so let me uh remind you or tell you
for the first time what the k sum
problem is it's it's extremely natural
um
uh and seems very fundamental in the
study of fine grained hardness
um so the input to the k-sum problem
it's the computational problem it has
some input um there are a bunch of
numbers in zq so a bunch of group
elements in in the group zq
um
uh and you should think of the parameter
regime where sort of m and q are
uh m and q are going to infinity
um and k is is maybe a large constant or
maybe going to infinity but rather
slowly relative to m and q
um
and the goal is simply to find
a k-tuple of your elements that sum to
zero modulo q
so you might have seen a variance of
this problem in different groups like
over the integers or um uh uh over like
z q to the n or whatever um it doesn't
really matter much sort of everything
i'm going to say works over
uh your favorite abelian group if you
have a favorite a billion group um but
uh it's gonna be easiest for me in this
talk to to discuss um uh zq
um and so just remember the the
parameter setting that i'm in i think if
k is like a constant or or maybe
something that's going to infinity very
slowly and q and m are sort of the
um uh parameters that are asymptotic
that are uh uh really going to infinity
okay
so of course this is some computational
problem and uh we're all computer
scientists here so so the question that
we ask is uh what's the fastest
algorithm for this problem and there's a
sort of naive brute force algorithm that
runs in time roughly m to the k or sort
of more accurately about m choose k
um so i'm going to hide low order terms
um throughout this talk um and of course
this algorithm works just by sort of
enumerating all possible k tuples um and
just checking uh for each one whether or
not the the given k2 pulse sums to zero
and once you find one uh uh you output
it
um
that you can actually do better than
this there's a slightly nontrivial
algorithm which is a meet in the middle
algorithm which runs in time roughly m
to the k over two um
uh again i'm like hiding low order terms
uh uh uh people who study this problem
will get annoyed with me and say i
should say m to the ceiling of k over
two the distinction is really rather
important but for the sake of this talk
i don't really care so much so there's a
meet in the middle algorithm where you
sort of enumerate all possible k over
two tuples and then a disjoint
collection of k over two tuples and you
merge them together somehow
um
and in fact if you don't care about the
constant of the exponent which again uh
for my purposes for the sake of this
talk we don't um this is actually tight
so there's a very nice lower bound due
to um petrasquin williams showing that
you can't do better than m to the order
k
um assuming uh the exponential time
hypothesis eth so
so um a very well known complexity
theoretic hypothesis which some people
believe in some don't i i think i
believe in it
um
uh but actually this isn't the only
algorithm like non-trivial algorithm
that we know for this problem there's
also kind of an entirely different
algorithm uh or really a pair of
algorithms you can either use the finite
fourier transform or sorry the fast
fourier transform or um dynamic
programming to get an algorithm that
runs in time roughly q so in time
roughly the size of the group
um
uh and you've probably seen something
like this
at least in the context of subset sum as
opposed to decay sum like you probably
know that
in a subset sum problem if your input
values are not very large then you can
solve it faster than just enumerating
[Music]
this is the sort of analogous result in
uh case on land
um
and again this result is tight so
there's a lower bound a very nice lower
bound by uh buddha quite recent
showing that if you believe scth
then you can't do better than q to the
one minus epsilon so this is quite a
tight lower bound it's even tied up to
the constant in the exponent
um
[Music]
uh uh so like what this tells us is that
they're kind of two different regimes of
um uh k-sum uh what i'll call the sparse
regime and the dense regime and there's
kind of a phase transition between them
in the sparse regime when m is much much
smaller than q to the one over k
um the fastest algorithm is this meet in
the middle time algorithm
uh uh and that's tight at least up to
the constant in the exponent um assuming
eth and in the dense regime uh when m is
really quite large then running an m to
the k times not the smartest idea
instead you should just run in queue
time
uh using uh dynamic programming or fft
um
and again this is optimal
um
so okay uh it seems like we've kind of
figured out this problem there's there's
maybe not so much to say about it
anymore because this wonderful work has
resolved everything
but i'm not interested in the worst case
problem i am interested in the average
case problem at least for this purposes
of this talk so what do i mean by the uh
average case k sum problem
well um
in this problem it's the same problem
except now my input
is uh uniformly random elements
a1 through am and zq instead of uh
arbitrary worst case elements they're
uniformly random so this is you know the
most natural average case version of the
problem and the goal is exactly the same
i again want to find um a k2 ball of my
input elements that sums to zero modulo
q
um
and notice that this
at least the way i've defined it here
this problem doesn't even make sense
unless m is much larger than q to the
one over k right because um uh if m is
not much larger than q to the one over k
then like a simple sort of union bound
argument will show you that
um uh actually with high probability
there will not be a solution um so i
suppose i could prove hardness uh for
this problem but it wouldn't be very
fair i'd be i'd be proving that it's
hard to find a solution that doesn't
exist um so it's not very interesting so
um at least the way i've defined the
average case case sum it's only
interesting in the dense regime it's
only interesting when you have a lot of
samples
um so again we can think of algorithms
for this problem
um and of course uh
i showed you on the previous slide that
there's a worst case algorithm that runs
in time roughly q roughly the size of
the group uh using fft and dynamic
programming it's a worst case algorithm
which means it also works in the average
case of course the average case can only
be easier than the worst case um
certainly can't be any harder
and remember in the worst case this
algorithm was actually uh
this this upper bound was actually tight
at least assuming scth we can't do any
better than this uh up to some some
lower order terms
um
uh
so you might think that this is tight in
in in the average case as well but it's
actually not
um there's a very nice algorithm uh it's
a bit of a difficult algorithm to
attribute to anyone because it's sort of
been discovered a few different times
it's very natural i'll show you the
algorithm so i usually call it the bkw
algorithm for bloom collide wasserman
because that's how i first learned about
it it was also described by uh wagner in
a slightly different context some people
call it the generalized birthday
algorithm but anyway it gets this really
kind of quite surprising um speed up
in particular instead of running in time
q it runs in time q to the 1 over log k
so even for a relatively small k this is
still like a significant polynomial
speed up for large k this is kind of
huge
and notice like this is like a real
separation right because if you believe
scth then you have to believe that um
the worst case problem can't be solved
in time better than q
um
but the average case problem provably
can be solved in time q to the 1 over
log k so really quite a bit faster
so there's a real gap between the worst
case and the average case here
and
i should note um that actually the vkw
wagner algorithm works in a very
specific regime it works in the regime
where we have so many samples m we have
q to the one over log k samples um
actually it's essentially a linear time
algorithm linear in m that only works
when m is very large
um and actually this is like not so
unreasonable um often in the in the
average case setting really i don't
think of m as sort of a fixed parameter
instead i kind of imagine that my my
algorithm has a button that it can press
and every time it presses the button it
receives um another a and it can just
press that button as many times as it
wants of course every time it presses
the button um
costs one time step um so the bkw wagner
algorithm presses the button many many
times q to the one over log k times it
gets q to the one over log case samples
um and once it has that many samples uh
uh it runs extremely efficiently
basically linear time
okay
um uh uh so that's the the average case
setting um and of course uh uh as a
complexity theorist um uh uh what i
wanna do here is prove that um this is
optimal right so i have an algorithm i
have an upper bound uh i want to prove a
lower bound and that's in fact what what
we do with uh zika in the node um in
particular we show that you can't do
better than q to the order one over log
k
um for the average case problem um
uh the conjecture that we use is not a
standard conjecture it's not sdth it's
not eth um you can view this as a
weakness of
our work it's a conjecture about the
hardness of a certain worst-case lattice
problem um so what we're getting is a
worst case average case reduction um a
fine grained worst case damage case
reduction um
but it's from a problem that people
typically don't study um in this context
so you can view that as a weakness of
our work but it's also worth noting like
the the problem which i'm not going to
even bother to define i'm not going to
tell you what a lattice is let alone
what the problem is um is a really well
studied problem and it's well studied in
particular by cryptographers um and up
to
various minor details if you could
falsify the conjecture um the hypothesis
under under which we show this hardness
result then you would break a bunch of
crypto and a bunch of cryptographers
would be annoyed with you um so modulo
annoying a bunch of cryptographers we
can we believe this hypothesis um uh uh
so non-standard but reasonable i think
is is a fair way to characterize it
okay
so um before i show you our reduction um
this is only a 30-minute talk it's it's
a simpler reduction let me uh uh show
you
um uh the bkw wagner algorithm because
our reduction can be viewed um at least
in hindsight as a modification of this
algorithm uh also it's really quite
beautiful and if you've never seen it
before that's a shame you should see it
uh so here it is um
[Music]
i'm going to assume for simplicity that
my parameters have a nice form in
particular i'm going to assume that k
remember i'm looking for a k sum i'm
going to assume that k is an integer
power of 2. it's 2 to the l i'm going to
assume that q is also excuse me it's
also an l power it's a p to the l
um and remember
bkw wagner only works in the regime
when m is much much larger than q to the
1 over log k which means q to the one
over l which means p
and you'll see where that comes out
uh so the idea here is i have a bunch of
integers uh in z q so i have a bunch of
integers modulo q
um and q is an lth power it's it's p to
the l so it's quite natural to write
these integers in base p right so i can
write an integer a and zq is a equals b0
plus b1 times p plus p2 times b squared
etc
um so here these bi are just the
um
the digits or bits or whatever of a in a
base b
and the idea of the bkw wagner algorithm
is if i want to find a k sum
uh that that is zero modulo q it
suffices to find a case on the zero
modulo
p n zero modulo p squared and zero
modulo p cubed and zero modulo p to the
four et cetera
so i'm going to sort of do this
iteratively i'm going to sort of zero
out the
zeroth digit first and the first digit
and the second digit and eventually i'll
have zeroed out all the digits
so here's how the algorithm works the
first thing that i do
is i try to zero out the the first digit
so the the first digit
of your base p representation in other
words i find
many disjoint pairs i and j such that a
ai plus aj is zero modulo p
um
and uh there are a bunch of things to
notice here first of all if m is much
much larger than p which is my
assumption then not only will such pairs
exist but there will be many such pairs
um basically every um uh ai and bi the
same here or
i'm sorry is a i and b i the same or
uh so maybe my notation is slightly
confusing um uh i guess b b is b 0 is a
i mod p
yeah but here i guess i'm i'm just
writing things mod p and i'm forgetting
about the b's yeah so i'm actually not
going to use the b's again that was just
kind of to explain what's going on at a
high level does that make sense
yes okay okay cool sorry about that um
okay so uh uh because my inputs are
random i expect to have many collisions
so i expect to find many a i's such that
there's a j where aj equals minus ai
uh in fact i expect sort of every ai to
have um a friend a j that equals minus a
i and i'll just uh uh uh collect all
such pairs
um uh uh
and group them together so i've sort of
zeroed out the um
[Music]
uh uh the the first bit or the zeroth
bit if you like um the next thing i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna look for pairs of
pairs so i'm gonna look for four tuples
uh i1 j1 i2 j2 that uh sum to zero
modulo p squared um and the way that i
do this is um
uh well by looking at the sums of my
pairs modulo p squared um
and looking for uh uh uh
uh sums of pairs that sum to the
negatives of each other
um and uh i think i maybe forgot to say
this but notice that i can do this in
more or less linear time in m right
because i could just sort all the sums
um uh uh modulo p squared so i can do
that like m log n m time or whatever and
then i just need to check for each sum
whether or not my my list contains um
the negation of the sum um so this can
be done very very efficiently more or
less linear time
um okay and then i just keep going so
i'm going to do this a total of l times
after the i step i'll have um uh uh i'll
have uh 2 to the i tuple that sums to um
zero modulo p to the i
um and in particular this means that f
after the l step i'll have a two to the
l tuple and two to the l equals k so
i'll have a k pupil um that sums to zero
modulo p to the l which is q so in other
words i'll have a solution to
um my uh original k substance
um and of course i'm relying really
heavily here on um uh the fact that m is
so large that not only do i have a case
on modulo 2 but i also have many two
sums modulo p which is not guaranteed
without this assumption that m is large
and i'm also
relying on the assumption that my input
was uh uniformly random
so that i can expect to actually have
these things um right and we know that
that's necessary because we know that
there's a lower bound um in in the worst
case world uh assuming scth so if this
worked in the worst case then we would
uh
violate scth and that would annoy some
people so we won't do that um okay
cool
so that's the bkw wagner algorithm now
i'm going to use this idea
to
um uh to show hardness of of k-sum
um
uh uh and of course i need to reduce
from some problem the problem that i'm
gonna reduce to is a problem that's
really well studied in in crypto and in
the lattice world that looks
suspiciously like casom very very
suspicious to like k some it's called
sis or short integer solutions um and uh
the inputs to this problem well it's a1
through am
sampled uniformly at random from
z q now q is a capital q not a lowercase
q that's the only difference um
and the goal is to find
um
x1 through xm uh oh my notation's messed
up here it should say x1 through xm such
that the sum of a i xi is 0 mod q
and the xi's have small l1 norm
um so if you squint and you don't worry
so much about the fact that the xi's
don't necessarily need to be 0 1
sis is just end sum
um uh which in some sense is really
silly i've just changed the letter k to
the letter m to the letter n um but
actually the big difference here is that
like the parameters really matter so in
the k sum world what i'm interested in
is constant k and in the sis world i'm
thinking of n as going to infinity um
uh uh so that's the difference i'm
thinking of n as being
relatively large uh compared to m say
comparable to m
uh uh whereas in the case of world
thinking of k is constant and m going to
infinity um so that's the difference and
this problem in this setting
is very well studied again in the
cryptal literature in particular we know
it's worst case hardness um i tai showed
all the way back in 1996
that sas which is basically just end sum
is at least as hard as some worst case
lattice problem
on n dimensional lattices and again i'm
not going to even define this problem
but this problem is thought to be two to
the order and hard
um
uh so we have like a very very strong
worst case average case reduction um for
this problem actually it turns out like
this specific version of the problem is
not the standard way it's written um
this this worst case start uh to average
case uh reduction
um was was only proven uh much later by
jinx in 2016.
um uh but it's very similar okay
question so the reason you need to take
you to be so large is so you can
conjecture exponential hardness or
uh no the reason i need to take q to be
so large it's the same
because i need there to be uh uh
solutions right so my parameter regimes
are a little different now um uh uh but
this is um uh the parameter regime that
i need in order
uh for there to be uh uh
uh wait okay sorry i'm confused one sec
uh no yes exactly what you said was
right i need q to be large uh for
hardness sorry yes and i think there was
a question asked
i don't know if you can see it i cannot
see it here in the zoom box uh i think i
can see it on my ipad does your
parameter regime imply a solution always
exists and thus a lower bound under eths
is unlikely yes parameter my parameter
regime uh i guess that a solution uh not
always exist but almost always exists uh
exists with high probability and
therefore yes so like
like one way of thinking about what's
going on here is kind of i'm doing
complexity in like the tfnp world um
where uh uh solutions are likely um uh
it's not exactly tfnp of course because
it's an average case problem but i only
have a solution with higher probability
um uh but yeah i don't expect to see
like eth or scth hardness here partially
because um
uh uh you don't expect to reduce um a
three sat or whatever to a total problem
and this is more or less a total problem
i hope that answers your question cool
okay more questions this is this is
wonderful
okay
so our goal here is going to be to
reduce sis which is an average case end
sum
uh to k sum um
and to get the parameters right remember
i want q to the one over log k hardness
um uh uh i know that uh s i s is two to
the order n hard under a reasonable
conjecture um so i want two to the n to
be like q to the one over log k
uh in order in order to make this go
through
okay
um so let me just remind you of the bkw
wagner algorithm because our reduction
is very similar to the wagner algorithm
and i want to point out that you can
view the bkw wagner algorithm as kinda
sorta almost a reduction what it's
reducing is it's a reduction from k sum
with modulus q
to twosome with modulus p it's not
exactly a reduction because it's like
not black box but that's basically what
it's doing right in every one of these
steps i'm solving a bunch of two-sum
instances mod p and i'm using those uh
solutions to solve a case stub modular
queue
um okay so
uh here's an idea of a reduction that
doesn't quite work uh and then i'll
explain uh how to fix it um so the idea
just like for bkw just like for bkw i'm
going to choose my parameters
conveniently in fact i can get away with
this because i know um hardness for sis
for
a wide range of parameters so i'm going
to take n to be k to the l so it's the
health power of k for some health and
i'm going to take big q to be little q
to that l this is very similar to what i
did with wagner um with bkw wagner
i'm going to use my case on oracle to
find m over k
disjoint k tuples that sum to 0 modulo
little q
so this is
again very similar to the bkw strategy
and then i'm going to use my case of
oracle again to find disjoint k squared
tuples
uh uh that sum to zero modulo q squared
etc
and
um uh after doing this l times i'm gonna
find an n tuple a k to the l which is an
n tuple um uh that sums to zero modulo
big q which is which is little q to the
l um so it's the same idea except i've
plugged in uh uh
instead of using two i'm using k and
little q
um and uh
uh
i'm using a case on oracle instead of
solving two sum instances
so this almost works comes really close
to working the only issue is that it
doesn't give an average case it doesn't
give an average case to average case
reduction um so let's think about this
for a second let's think about like the
distribution like how it would actually
do step one so for step one i don't just
need to find a single k tuple that sums
to zero mod q i need to find many many k
tuples it's sent to zero mod q yeah and
the most obvious way to do so would be
to
uh uh just call well the laziest way to
do so would be to call my case on oracle
on the same input over and over and over
again um and that's it sometimes it's
not bad because uh by definition my
input comes from an sis instance it is
in fact uniformly random so uh it is an
average case instance but of course if i
call my case somewhere called the same
input over and over and over again it's
just going to give me the same answer
every time so that's no good
uh so the next thing you could imagine
doing is
uh uh call my case on oracle on the
first
uh m all ml elements and then call it on
um uh m minus k elements where i've
taken out the k elements from uh
whatever k tuple it gives me the first
time and then i call it an m minus two k
elements in m minus 3k elements etc and
i do that roughly m over k times uh to
get uh roughly m over k destroying uh k
tuples
um so this idea would work
if we had a worst case case i'm oracle
the problem is
that if i try to do this with an average
case case in oracle it can misbehave um
in particular um uh uh i think it's
helpful to imagine that our case on
oracle has some preferences for example
suppose our case of oracle only likes to
output um
k sums that tend to have even integers
in them right so if we had such an
oracle and uh it tends to to find uh k2
pulls with even integers after i run it
a bunch of time
um after i run it a bunch of times uh
it's going to
um
uh the the instances that i'm going to
start calling it on are going to be
depleted of of even integers and it's
going to complain it's going to say
that's no good that's not an average
case instance i have like even integers
there are no even integers here and it's
going to refuse to cooperate
um
so uh uh so this does work for a worst
case case i'm oracle and it does in fact
give if you plug in all the parameters
which i'm not going to bother to do
um q to the 1 over log k hardness for
worst case k sum um but that's
not interesting right because we already
know q to the one minus epsilon hardness
uh uh for worst case case sum so we get
a worse result um and it's it's not
particularly interesting it does not
work for average case hardness
and now let me just sort of sketch
briefly the the main technical um uh
step in the paper which is um we convert
uh uh little m samples a1 through am
into big m samples um
uh uh
a1 prime through a m-prime where each of
uh the ai primes is the sum of a random
k-tuple of the a-x
um and the idea here is that i can take
many many such k-2 bowls and i can sort
of blow up my number of samples uh uh
then run this algorithm on dish
completely disjoint sets uh sort of
collapse down the number of samples that
i have and then blow up again collapse
down blow up again collapse down
um
uh uh and it turns out that this works
that the ai primes will be statistically
close to independent uniform samples um
and if i get k sums of the ai primes
this gives me k squared sums of the ai
um anyway this is the most technical
part of our work um uh it it it takes
some work to go through but i think the
high level idea um uh uh for this
audience and for this talk is more
interesting in the details
so let me just summarize what's going on
so we have a set so before this work
we'd essentially type bounds uh for the
worst case case on there's this sort of
transition that happens between the
sparse and dense regime
um and we show more or less tight lower
bound for average case case some in the
dense regime
and we do so using non-standard worst
case uh fine-grained hardness assumption
uh which is the hardness of a certain
lattice problem
and i just want to leave you with an
open question which is more of like a
future direction or a challenge or
something which is i feel like uh a
k-sum uh uh is a problem that people
really care about in fine grain
complexity um uh and so now we have this
fact the average case k-some is hard in
the dense regime uh under a reasonable
worst case assumption so the obvious
next step to me seems to be what can we
reduce uh k sum to uh in other words
what other uh uh average case fine grain
hardness results um uh can we prove
um uh uh given this result
um so thanks i think uh uh i ran
slightly over time so i apologize for
that but that's it
we started a bit late too so think let's
think no
thank you
uh are there
any questions from the audience or from
the online audience so uh so benny has
a question so maybe you can read it out
uh yeah so benny asked if he said that i
showed that bkw is tight in in this
particular context um and he's wondering
if i can use that to conclude that bkw
is tight in in the lpn regime so
basically so ben is basically asking
about modulus q equals two
um so i didn't say very much about what
uh restrictions on the modulus i need um
it turns out that i can't handle
arbitrarily small moduli i can handle
constant modulus but not arbitrarily
small constant modulus um
uh so in particular i do not know how to
prove uh
such results for for q equals two um for
the lpn regime i think i think that
would be um pretty exciting uh and i
don't
i don't know that there's a fundamental
barrier i just know that like our
particular techniques don't work there
we did we did try
so is there a direct connection between
lpn and subset some because in lpn you
have also some noise
or that's uh yeah i i i suspect like
um uh uh so sis the problem that i
showed is closely related to lwe um
and uh uh just like sis is really tell
w-e-l-p-n is related to
some uh average case
uh uh short coding problem and so i
suspect when benny said lpn what he
really meant was i think it's sometimes
called binary svp
which is a
a kind of variant of uh
uh uh sis in in the q equals two world
um
so i think i think yeah there's this i
don't think there's a very good name for
it which is probably why benny said okay
okay uh any question any more questions
from either
the physical or the virtual audience
thanks let's thank noah again then
for very nice talk
and we'll pick up in about 25 minutes uh
so meet back here at 11. thanks
cool